how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
get in double I first thought of the
concept of hybridization when I tried to
understand how people who lack power and
authority can actually enter a
negotiation and make demands which
combine or mix-up or destabilize the
assumptions of power on which they have
been for their which they're asked to
invite it to converse oh I think
post-colonial studies is nothing other
than thinking about the moment of
enlightenment in relation to
colonization thinking about the
construction of nation and civil society
in the West while Western powers were
involved in creating colonies in the
what we now call the global south of
course that's what not what it was
called in those days so post-colonial
studies is about the connections between
things that we have been often not put
together to say that the Enlightenment
also had its origins in empire that
Bentham's notion of the panopticon was
first tried out in in India that John
Stuart Mill the you know whose word on
Liberty is accepted everywhere in the
world says that I am a Democrat in my
own country proponent of liberalism and
a despot in somebody else's country as a
member of a colonial power is the
subject of a colonial power so John
Stuart Mill's paradox I am and a
Democrat in my country and a despot in
somebody else's country gives you in ash
in brief the whole story
about post-colonial studies how do we
think about democracy and despotism
coexisting in different parts of the
world but at the same time and what are
the lessons we learn from there and of
course this issue is one that bedevils
all of modernity slavery after all was
considered to be an economically
advanced modern concept of dealing with
questions of trade and production Empire
nobody said imperialism or Empire was
unjust
initially the justification for it was
that it would modernize and Christianize
many countries that were actually being
ruled upon by oriental despots so so
really post-colonial studies is about
the paradoxes of modernity and the
contradictions of the Enlightenment
which are very much with us here today
if you think about the invasion of many
countries in the in in the Middle East
Afghanistan and so on I don't intend
putting them in a historical context
which you know but many of these Middle
Eastern interventions by anglo-american
and other powers and European powers was
in the name of spreading democracy of
spreading civil society so the old
paradoxes of empire and the growth of
the nation exists today in relation to
interventions in countries based on the
new notion of global progress
the word colonial as a general concept
as I suppose as you know start the
Derby's we have a very clear idea of
what the colonies were and how they
don't exist anymore
but do you find that actually looking
back on those things and sometimes in
muddy thinking about the idea of
colonialism today well I have a problem
with the term post-colonial when it is
narrowly used for disciplinary
curricular purposes when people want not
to explore its wider connotations and
want to turn it into some kind of
codified canonical knowledge because as
I say the relevance of the post-colonial
movement of thought is a race is about
modernity the concept of modernity in
general it's about the notion of the
Enlightenment and how do we rethink the
Enlightenment now and what are the
lineages what are the inheritances of
these of these parts and don't forget
that the Enlightenment as I said earlier
or liberalism are as much ideologies
read in the colonies as they are in the
urban metropolitan centers so I only
have a problem with with people who see
it in a narrow disciplinary sense
current day forms of the oppression of
people's global inequality have to be
defined better than calling them simply
colonial because we don't I mean we had
there are elements of colonization the
great inheritances of racism for
instance that are used now in in
thinking about other cultures and other
countries but we don't strictly have a
colonial form of governance at the
global level we have more forms of
ethnic or populist nationalism
or tribal nationalism across the world
you think about India then you have that
concept of tribal nationalism against
and where the Muslims are seen as the
enemy within you go to the United States
you have a majoritarian view which is
largely white anglo-saxon and who the
enemies they're the enemies are the
dissident intellectuals the enemies of
the Democrats the enemies of the
Mexicans the enemies of the migrants in
Britain around brexit same sort of issue
we want to claim back our country I use
the word tribal nationalism now as a
global phenomenon Venezuela
Turkey India Britain United States
Hungary Poland and what is tribal
Nationals the tribal nationalism is
consists of two things one large
powerful men who play on a kind of
tyrannical charisma on a tyrannical
charisma to represent the majority and
the majorities rights and who are the
enemies the enemies are those minorities
who threaten the majority so tribal
nationalism is continually saying to the
majority you are being threatened you
are being you've got to claim your
country back make make America make
America great again which is like saying
make America hate again
has exploded in the last decade is that
something you think that is you know
it's cyclical you know does it come up
time time again or is actually always
present and it's just disguised by
certainly kind of government that's a
very interesting question the fact that
I'm using the term tribal nationalism
today it does give does make me think of
it's not necessarily cyclical history
but it's iterative history because the
term actually comes from Hannah Arendt
in the origins of totalitarianism
describing the interwar period where you
had many nations coming apart people
large-scale migration minority treaties
being written and there you began to
have as she put it a kind of tribal
nationalist perspective so the fact that
today in in in in this and in in you
know in in 2018 we're talking about a
phenomenon that Hannah Arendt identified
in when she was writing in the 50s about
a period which was in the interwar
period say 1914 1918 and she was using
it in the 50s to describe what happened
also in Europe near the Second World War
so you how many iterations do you have
you have the the interwar period of
tribal nationalism you have the the
forty the you know the post second per
second world war and indeed the
construction during the Second World War
of race during the Holocaust and then
you have a Hannah Arendt picturing and
writing about it confined in the term in
the 50s and now I'm using it again in
2018 so I'm not saying these are
cyclical things they don't start from
the same place go around and end in the
same place but they are iterative
movements the second question is why are
they always
Prest are these things somehow repressed
and there's democracy or democratic
discourse produce a kind of pretty cover
which actually hides these things I
don't think that is the case I think
that each time you have these forms of
populism they're certain of populist
nationalism or tribalism they have
certain elements in common and different
elements so element in common with our
own time is the fact that whatever the
economic crises are whatever the
political crises are there are a group
of people largely national minorities
sexual minorities migrant migrants and
refugees people who are marked by the
brush of race who become them will
become the visible symptoms of the
problem they become the visible thing so
that is some thing that the iteration
has in common the difference of course
is that now we have new technologies of
connectivity now we have a whole sense
of what a globally networked world is
with all its asymmetries and
inequalities that economic structure is
new so you have an earlier kind of
recognizable mindset or political vision
of tribal nationalism now intersected
with a new set of global economic and
political arrangements and I think
that's the way to look at this issue
well I think it's extremely successful
bringing together of people who are very
thoughtful but come from very different
parts of the world and very different
interests and very different disciplines
and I think that it's been wonderfully
curated get your tickets for the world's
largest music and philosophy festival
how the light gets in